quand vous voyez sur village un peu leur
mental dans cinq mois ils seront au
cameroun alexis et jordan partant projet
humanitaire avec l'association ces cas
le but de ce projet c'est de aider les
enfants qui en ont le plus besoin de
nous montrer aussi en quelque sorte que
nous on a des choses on a beaucoup plus
de choses et on se rend pas compte de la
chance qu'on a et nous allons construire
des écoles et des peintres des écoles à
portée du sable faire tous ces petites
choses qui vont pouvoir aider et avancer
le projet cette association but d'aider
les parents d'élèves qui s'ébat dans les
ménages ce que voilà les enfants qui
savoir des places dans des écoles vous
savez qu'au cameroun des villages qui
sont basés dans des endroits zones
rurales en quelque sorte abandonnées par
l'état et peut il manque des places dans
des causes c'est pénible pour des
familles pour financer leur projet ils
ont demandé le passeport citoyen les
deux frères ont présenté un dossier à la
commune de bois d'arcy c'est un
dispositif que la municipalité a lancé
en 2014 en vue donc d'aider des jeunes
de 16 à 25 ans arcisien mener à bien
donc un projet donc un bafin a permis un
projet humanitaire depuis quelques
semaines donc c'est un engagement de
leur part et d'une autre sur lequel on
avance donc nous paie une partie allant
de 200 à 300 euros en fonction du projet
qui nous est présenté alexis jordan ont
obtenu chacun la totalité de la
subvention en contrepartie ils
s'engagent à travailler quelques heures
pour la commune décollage pour l'afrique
prévu en avril 2017